she hits me but
[Music]
three celebrities 3 tennis challenge 3
physical challenge a grand finale
welcome to star set and match season
selection of players guillaume pley one
meter eighty five animators
comedians little princes be a
poster in sports  christophe
michalak 1 m 83 pastry chefs sos
autism backhand like agassi he
would hurt 50 and maurice it's
only happiness perfect mastery of the
splits
level 2 the hunchback plays with
pauline parmentier one meter seventy
seven young retirees  play live
world champion cédric pioline to
put 90 professional tennis player
do the gypsy wall polhenri nature 1
m 85
former pro sports player and
backhand chips jumped see you tomorrow physical challenge
the hunchback you crucial training
improved his stability his reflexes and
also to recover his proprioception
after an injury
your challenge to balance
on the hunchback takes a good response to the
quiz
the challenge starts in three 2 1 go
the longest game in
roland garros history was 6:33 yes we and
racket was your faith made of granite
it's fake fake fake it was wooden
rafael nadal won 19 times  roland
garros yes you need a well ranked player and
call a seeded there is it true
the current tournament director of roland
garros and emmanuel macron it's wrong yes
it's wrong and pelé slam roland garros
was a tennis player or not at the  aviators
the new course inaugurated at roland
garros in 2000 in 2019 is called the
simone mathieu and yannick noah winning
roland garros at only 23 years old it's
true it's true the counting of points
due to tennis 15 30 40 comes from the game of
palm karoui delivering the
spoon service was invented by a pastry chef
not a plasterer and is the crack no to the
panama and clothing accessories
symbolic of the tournament it's wrong no
it's true the backhand method was
invented by john  robert no
yesh halfway  asks a tennis because
there are two three questions
it was obvious and now the scores
challenge tennis the volley the volley one of the
offensive strokes in tennis it does
not require force but
only bouncing the ball on the theme
to  this challenge you know three tries
to make the longest rally on the
fly with your coach fully for the
challenge
the challenge starts in three 2 1 go
well my record to sad people and tell
me we exploded what's the problem  record
you have it for real but michalak
it's wrong I leave at 7 p.m. before
means with barely 13 true
aesthetically it was not the same
master getting lost
in the poetic name not bad so how much
is 113 113
not  bad not bad frankly it didn't
fail see you speak I took them like
that like that like that I was why I thought I was
very good bah me anyway 25
but I liked the moment too much in any
case ah ah sorry to  the 135
I had said bravo bravo he told me that
flap on f  let's have a point on the
scores in the next level the
rhythm ladder
the smash we give it star it was match
season 3